c'est dimanche de Pâques pour les
orthodoxes et dans la petite église
russe du quartier Palermo de Buenos
Aires les portes sont ouvertes pour la
bénédiction
il fut une époque où il n'y avait que
des vieux mais cette année c'est la cure
de jouvence pour chaque couple qui
arrive avec son nouveau-né un autre de
toute évidence attend un bébé des femmes
beaucoup de femmes russes enceintes et
sur le point d'accoucher
l'enfant de Maria est attendue cette
semaine celui de Yelena aussi mais on la
reverra plus tard parce qu'elle veut se
reposer elle s'apprête à vivre un des
plus grands jours de leur vie mais à
15000 km de la maison ici en Argentine
terre promise des jeunes parents russes
Tatiana mosanova a couché d'un petit
garçon au mois de décembre en pleine
euphorie de la victoire de l'Argentine à
la Coupe du monde ils l'ont appelé
Samuel Sergio
en l'honneur du joueur étoile de leur
terre d'accueil
mais l'essentiel c'est qu'il sera libre
de faire et d’être ce qu'il veut dit sa
mère grâce aux droits du sol Samuel est
née argentin et en vertu des lois parmi
les plus permissifs du monde ses parents
sont déjà résidents et pourront devenir
officiellement citoyen et aussi d'ici
deux ans
ils ont fui la répression du sel gay qui
a été battu sauvagement pour son
opposition et son front parler
plus de 22000 russe on voyageait en
Argentine selon les autorités la moitié
sont des femmes qui aussitôt arrivé sur
rue vers les cliniques d'obstétrique
public et privé
le docteur Mathias ouanga dit qu'il n'a
jamais rien vu tel en Argentine ils
croient que ce n'est que le début
[Musique]
qu'elle prenne des risques énormes en
prenant l'avion depuis la Russie au-delà
du cap des 34 semaines de grossesse
mais pour Yelena et son mari Youri
c'était la seule option viable il est
hors de question que leur enfant vienne
au monde en Russie
[Musique]
ici sur Youtube qu'ils ont appris que
Jelena qui est russe pouvait entrer sans
visa et s'installer sans problème en
Argentine mais il travaillait et obtenir
des soins de santé gratuit
les autorités ont d'ailleurs ouvert une
enquête pour sévir contre des agences
privées comme celle-ci qui profitent de
la guerre pour vendre des forfaits tout
compris à prix d'or à ceux qui en ont
les moyens
tourisme de naissance ou exil politique
la question en flamme les plateaux de
télévision ou la directrice de
l'immigration de l'Argentine parle
d'abus et d'opportunisme flagrants
des couples russes n'ont aucune
intention de vivre en Argentine à temps
plein
c'est notre passeport parce qu'il est un
des plus sûrs et donne accès sans visa à
175 pays dans le monde
un discours discriminatoire de cette
avocat et qui va à l'encontre de tout ce
que l'Argentine garantit comme
protection depuis des centaines d'années
aux opprimés de ce monde
en this is the national
et c'est justement pour protéger son
fils à vie que Marie akonovalova a elle
aussi choisi de s'installer ici
elle est arrivée de Saint-Pétersbourg au
mois de février
à bord d'un avion qui transportait 32
autres femmes enceintes de Russie et qui
a aussitôt suscité la méfiance Maria a
été détenue avec cinq autres femmes sans
aucune raison valable interrogée puis
libérer 24 heures plus tard à la demande
d'un jugement
l'Argentine demeure aujourd'hui une
planche de salut pour ses enfants et
leurs parents
il est ma vie et il fait mon bonheur il
est tout pour nous
ici grâce à lui que nous avons un avenir